على عادته بسرواله وستورته العسكريين لكن
ليس من خلف الشاشات هذه المره الرئيس
الاوكراني في واشنطن بشخصه زياره
استثنائيه هي الاولى له منذ بدء الغزو
الروسي لبلاده قبل نحو عشره اشهر زاد من
استثنائيتها اعلان نظيره الامريكي
حيل صلابه التحالف الغربي في وجه روسيا
التي يتهم رئيسا
بانه لا ينوي ايقاف الحرب
اعتبر بدوره ان منظومه باتريوت هي الاقوى
في حزمه المساعدات مشددا في الوقت نفسه
على ان سلاما عادلا لبلاده لن ينطوي على
اي مساومه على سيادتها وحريتها وسلامه
اراضيها
احملوا اخبارا ساره لبلادي الرئيس بيد
اعلن عن حزمه
جديد دفاعي بحوالي مليار دولار امريكي
وجزء الاهم في هذه الحزمه هو منظومه
بطاريات باتريوت التي ستتيح لنا تعزيز
الدفاعاتنا الجويه بشكل كبير
من البيت الابيض
وحتى قبل ان يبدا بالكلام وقف المشرعون
الامريكيون وصفقه طويلانسكي الذي استهلك
كلامه بالقول ان بلاده حيه وتقاتل ولن
تستسلم ابدا على الضفه الاخرى تصعيد موسكو
سبق مغادرته
اعلن لكريم لان شحنات اسلحه امريكيه جديده
الى اوكرانيا ستؤدي الى تفاقم النساء فيما
وعد بوتين بمواصله تطوير قدرته جيشه وقوته
النوويه